the head of a top teacher's union ready
to go to battle to defend teaching
critical race theory
aft president randy weingarten slamming
critics and saying her union has
prepared
is prepared to fight in court to defend
teachers who push it in their classrooms
mark my words our union
will defend any member who gets in
trouble
for teaching honest history we have a
legal defense fund ready to go
teaching the truth is not
radical or wrong distorting history
and threatening educators for teaching
the truth
is what is truly radical and wrong
and weingarten who was with first lady
jill biden today
says the white house has her back
together we can support each other
because we also
know there's an administration in
washington dc
that has our back and an education
department
that truly respects your voices
as professionals in classrooms and
frankly
that starts with the first lady so jesse
this seems like an intimidation
tactic that uh miss weingarten is using
against parents who dare to speak out
they're bringing in the lawyers they're
threat threatening lawsuits and now
they're saying the white house is
involved
poor dr jill biden yeah that is not a
hill you want to die on critical race
theory
my goodness this country's against this
by like three to one
if the c.i.a katy were to invent a way
to subtly destroy a country it would be
teaching
critical race theory in our schools
randy is not a nice woman no bueno
geraldo
no bueno first she's going to embezzle
all the money that we gave them to not
teach
can't prove it but i will next year when
you see all the indictments because
that's their track record
then she kept all the kids out of school
you're making for an entire year
and then now that they're behind instead
of catching them up
she's just dragging them through the
dirty racial gutter it's a shame
it's disgusting and the parents aren't
taking it anymore
i have not seen the democratic party
this discombobulated trying to defend
something
than what they're doing with critical
race theory usually they're really on
message
like surprisingly on message this time
they're like oh we don't teach critical
race theory
oh actually we do we just teach it in
colleges oh actually we just teach it in
middle school but it's a good thing but
i can't define what it is but it's good
and it's not history katie right if they
have history class
i'm fine with teaching slavery in
history that it's already taught
we're talking about adding another topic
and it's it's rotten yeah dana they're
gaslighting the parents and they're also
calling them
bullies let's take a listen and get your
take
cultural warriors are labeling
any discussion of race
racism or discrimination as crt
to try to make it toxic they are
bullying teachers
and trying to stop us from teaching
students accurate history
dana well dismissing your critics as
racist
is basically just a way to say that i
don't have to deal with you anymore yeah
and it's also
telling the parents you're just confused
like they're not and
they are engaged and they've been to
more school board meetings than they
ever thought they would
in their entire lives many i think we
showed yesterday i think the number of
school board recall petitions are up
like a huge amount
and then they have people deciding to
run for the school board i mean this
escalated pretty quickly from
oh this is just an obscure elite theory
that no one even really pays attention
to we have a legal defense fund
in order to defend anybody who's going
to do it now here's the thing
of all the millions of members that are
teachers there's got to be some
that don't want to teach critical race
theory right will she defend them
that's a great question and i would
imagine that they're going to invite a
lawsuit
that will be very interesting by the
time it gets to the supreme court what
would happen
remember the union dues issue was
already dealt with and
they were pushed back on but if you're
in the union you don't have a choice you
have to pay so
now you are paying out of your paycheck
as a teacher
into the union you don't have a choice
and some of that money will be used to
defend critical race theory
even if you don't believe in it you know
greg now that kids have been
at home for a year and these teachers
unions are threatening to shut down
schools again
in the fall parents have been able to
see more of what their kids are learning
and we saw at the beginning they didn't
want teacher or parents to be listening
in on the zoom calls and the meetings
that the kids were having
well now we know why there's you know
they're saying that we don't teach
critical race theory
but the parents are seeing it firsthand
with the work that they're doing in
their homes at their kitchen table yeah
in fact i mean this is
where you can really get an edge on
these on these people because
you've got to define it and once you
define it
they're on the defense because the
practitioners will deny it
they'll say oh no crt does this we don't
teach that
but then it's documented it's in there
well we don't really do that
you don't even know what it is but the
first thing you got to realize it's a
theory
it's not history it's a theory it's
based on defining america
as an oppressor versus the oppressed it
uh it means that
no one is free from race that free that
race your skin color
actually defines your outcomes and that
that's the reason why we'll be eternally
divided
and uh the weirdest the worst thing
about it what makes it racist
is that it says that there are certain
specific attributes that are distinctly
white all right so that's racist we know
that's racist
and it's okay to bully a racist
that's what i've been told by the media
so if crt has racial components
and she's teaching this stuff she
deserves to be
bullied she should people to quote the
great maxine waters
should get in her face because she's
teaching
racist stuff to children lastly
get you know what let them run with this
stuff and get your kids out of these
schools
it is time for a separate track school
choice let these people crash and burn
if they want to destroy their children
have at it but if you're a parent
you get your kids out of there you go to
another school you move out of town if
you have to
let these people die with what they're
creating now there's this push to
disconnect
property taxes and money from schools
and attach it directly to individuals
meaning your kids
geraldo you know if you're a teacher in
a school and you're teaching reading
writing and math
that enables every student in the school
to be on the same playing field
when it comes to opportunity and success
in life but instead
teachers are focused on this garbage
that turns kids against each other and
they're bullying the parents
and threatening to dox them if they dare
say anything i i think that you're all
way too sensitive
when i i i rather when i was in school
the only black person in american
history i ever heard of was like jackie
robinson uh you were a lousy student
totally why would you let me finish you
must have cut class
let me finish it was you know the the
founding fathers and
uh you know i never i was never taught
that there was only one catholic among
the signers of the declaration of
independence
there's there's there's some good
there's some good
in uh 1619 and all these other
concepts they go overboard teachers are
way too progressive
parents could be insufferable too i had
lunch today
all right michael's great restaurant i
took my daughter
all about a plug alex both of them uh
you know
go to spence or my daughter soul went to
spencer on the left her friend alex of
best friends
the 15 year old say that the parents can
be insufferable too
the the teachers may go overboard let
the kids figure out you know what
wait wait i was having my i was at lunch
today at arby's do you have a picture of
me with my family yeah yeah
you ever heard of my desk the customer
is always right well
the parents and the students are the
customers they're paying the taxes
to be taught this stuff and if they
object to it that's true but then they
should do something what if you have a
totally obnoxious parent
who thinks something uh you know uh uh i
don't know you probably are the
obnoxious parents
i'm the nicest parent you're sensitive
all right anyway hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else